[Música]
olá pessoal
eu estou muito contente em estar aqui
hoje e compartilhar com vocês algumas
das minhas experiências dos meus sonhos
e quem sabe depois dessa nossa conversa
o meu sonho vira um pouquinho o sonho de
vocês eu vou compartilhar compartilhe
vou começar compartilhando uma dessas
experiências que eu tive um ano passado
à frente de um projeto um projeto que
foi de levar oficinas de debate e
argumentação para cerca de 70 crianças
em uma escola pública em um bairro de
periferia daqui em uma das oficinas a
gente dividiu as crianças em grupos cada
grupo tinha que preparar o melhor
argumento sobre um determinado assunto
que nós já tínhamos discutido com
critérios que nós já tínhamos
estabelecido
e aí gente nessa situação teve um garoto
um garoto que não queria contribuir no
grupo dele
a mediadora que estava lá no grupo
conversou com ele perguntou mas por que
por que você não quer contribuir e ele
disse não
dona eu sou burro se eu for contribuir
eu vou só trabalhar em equipe
a mediadora ela foi bastante habilidosa
acabou conseguindo fazer com que aquele
garoto participasse ativamente do seu
grupo
cada grupo apresentou os seus argumentos
e depois dessa apresentação eu junto com
todas as crianças eram crianças entre 10
e 12 anos
ajudei eles a encontrarem a descobrir em
qual daqueles argumentos é o melhor
argumento e adivinhem só a equipe
daquele garoto foi a equipe com o melhor
argumento sem sombra de dúvidas
acabada a oficina a mediadora voltou a
conversar com esse garoto e falou assim
olha tá vendo as suas contribuições
foram essenciais para a construção do
melhor argumento no seu grupo e da e da
sala e ele foi e falou assim para ela é
dona talvez eu não seja tão burro assim
até hoje essa história me arrepia a alma
porque primeiramente além de uma
história tocante
ela mostra que a gente está no caminho
certo
ela mostra aquele garoto com aquela
atividade com aquela situação pode
repensar a sua própria crença
desconstruir e a partir de novos
embasamentos reconstruir o que ele
pensava de si mesmo de uma forma mais
positiva de uma forma que ele podia ser
atuante na sua pequena comunidade que
naquele dia era o seu grupo de trabalho
com isso ele exerceu sobre si mesmo um
pensamento crítico e é sobre pensamento
crítico que eu quero falar um pouquinho
mais com vocês neste momento o
pensamento crítico ele é essencial na
nossa sociedade ainda mais uma situação
atual em que a gente tem uma gama de
informações de todos os lados
uma gama de informações que muitas vezes
vêm na forma de notícias falsas as
famosas sei 500 com pensamento crítico
você pode ter ferramentas para decidir
quando chega a notícia é falsa ou não o
que fazer com ela e acabaram caindo na
armadilha de compartilhando notícias que
na verdade não tem nada a ver o
pensamento crítico ele é objeto de
estudo de várias áreas de pesquisa entre
elas a filosofia a psicologia ea própria
educação que é a minha área de trabalho
eu vejo o pensamento crítico como
intimamente conectado com a minha missão
que é de fazer com que as pessoas tenham
mais diálogos que esses diálogos sejam
de mais qualidade e eu entendo como
diálogo de mais qualidade àqueles
diálogos que são mais simpáticos mais
construtivos e mais críticos com isso eu
quero trazer para vocês que nessa missão
que eu tenho de vida essa missão ela é
atual
eu demorei bastante para chegar a essa
conclusão de missão de vida
eu sempre me vi como educadora e sempre
atuei como educadora mas eu demorei pra
perceber a educação como central na
minha vida profissional eu desde pequena
é so de parnaíba no litoral do piauí e
desde pequena minha brincadeira favorita
era o que dá aula para as minhas bonecas
depois passei a aula os meus colegas de
sala ver até professor particular quando
tinha 13 anos me mudei para teresina
onde lá 1 depois de terminar o ensino
médio virei professora de crianças de 10
a 12 anos
dali eu fui para o rio de janeiro onde
estudei em engenharia pelo m&e enquanto
fazia graduação fazia o que dava aulas
depois me mudei para os estados unidos
lá fui fazer doutorado em química
computacional na tarde de melo na
universidade carnegie mellon em
pittsburgh e nessa universidade no
momento em que eu estava me aprofundando
na pesquisa daquela área da computação
lidando com computadores com beats
combates com programação com dados para
aquilo tudo isso me dá um imenso vazio
eu senti uma necessidade muito grande de
retomar o meu lado a educadora de
resgatar e de me aprimorar como educador
e passei a fazer alguns cursos na
própria universidade para melhorar minha
didática e medicar divulgação científica
e aí quando eu fiz 30 anos nessa unidade
a imagem pra muitas pessoas
faltando um ano para terminar o
doutorado caiu a ficha
toda vida eu coloquei a educação como
algo a mais na minha vida profissional e
não como centro e eu precisava mudar
essa história
junto com essa decisão a decisão de
voltar pro brasil terminou o doutorado
gente não fiquei sem treinar não
terminei voltei para o brasil e vim
parar aqui em são carlos para me tornar
pesquisadora na área de educação
trabalhando especialmente com as
metodologias ativas com a argumentação
tanto em espaços formais de ensino que
são as salas de aula
quanto fora das salas de aula e dentro
dessa formação dessa experiência dessa
teoria toda que eu tenho me aprofundado
eu percebo que o educador pra que ele
consiga desenvolver o pensamento crítico
para que ele tenha ferramentas e possa
desenvolver ele precisa pensar em alguns
aspectos entre eles
ele precisa é isso aqui é um carro né
entre eles ele precisa se aprimorar se
aprimorar em que sentido ele precisa
entender sobre o pensamento crítico
sobre o seu próprio processo de
construção do pensamento crítico ea
partir daí conseguir dar aulas melhores
no assunto isso embasado isso é claro é
esperada embasado por várias pesquisas
têm uma uma pesquisa que fez uma análise
que começou com mais sete mil artigos
teses dissertações em que se falava
sobre o pensamento crítico e nessa
pesquisa chegou à conclusão que
professores que estavam mais bem
preparados da sua formação em pensamento
crítico eles obtinham esse resultado
melhor com seus alunos é claro
então esse aprimoramento ele pode vir
tanto o que da universidade que pode dar
um norte para aquele professor como pode
vir de auto estudo de livros de
conteúdos de internet de cursos ele pode
continuar sua formação desse assunto mas
além deles se aprimorar o que ele
precisa ele precisa entender e aplicar
ferramentas que façam com que aquele
educando aquele aluno dele possa
realmente ter situações em que ele vai
discutir e vai desenvolver o pensamento
crítico então ele precisa trazer o
protagonismo do seu aluno que pode ser
feito inclusive com as metodologias
ativas e para quem isso pode ser feito
pra todo mundo
a partir de das crianças mais novas da
educação infantil a ser uma lei tão que
é uma pesquisadora que brasileira ela
chegou à conclusão de que crianças tão
novas contas mais novas que três anos
que estão começando a desenvolver sua
linguagem já utilizam de elementos
argumentativos então daí pra frente a
gente só a gente precisa continuar essa
construção só que você pode me falar tá
tudo bem eu não estou numa sala de aula
assim
quero que o meu filho a minha neta tem a
oportunidade de ver o pensamento crítico
já sei que é importante eu quero essa
oportunidade que eu posso fazer
você e eu quero que você pare e pense e
reflita nesse momento tudo que eu falei
da sala de aula
tudo que eu falei que o educador pode
fazer pode ser você
sendo você esse educador
você precisa primeiramente desenvolver o
próprio pensamento crítico para que você
seja uma mudança positiva nas pessoas
que estão ao seu redor no seu sobrinho
sua sua filha seus netos nos seus
vizinhos no seu grupo de trabalho você
precisa primeiro se desenvolver com o
pensador crítico e aqui eu vou trazer
três dicas três dicas que vão ajudar
nesse processo de você se tornar um
pensador crítico
a primeira dica é a escuta
então discutir
imagine imagine que alguém chega
contando uma notícia pra você
ao ouvir essa notícia escute de verdade
com a mente eo coração abertos porque a
gente tem a mania de na verdade enquanto
está ouvindo alguém falando você já está
pensando na resposta quando aquilo que a
pessoa está falando especialmente se
você contrário aquela opinião então eu
peço convido vocês que faz o exercício
escutem empaticamente ativamente de
verdade não só interromper uma pessoa
com as pré concepções que você já tem
aquele assunto
mesmo que você considera que aquilo que
você já sabe a verdade absoluta
a segunda dica que a gente tem é a
prenda qualquer assunto que vem até você
talvez você já saiba que esse assunto
talvez você não saiba se aprofunde
naquele assunto
busque fontes confiáveis mesmo que você
já tenha buscado já tenha encontrado já
ter chegado à conclusão busque fontes
confiáveis que pensem o contrário do que
você já pensa porque pelo confronto de
idéias que a gente consegue construir
conclusões que sejam melhores embasadas
que sejam pensando nos diversos lados
daquela situação ea terceira dica é a
análise
ouviu a notícia escutou aprendeu a
análise análise realmente aquele
argumento que foi trazido ele é um bom
argumento ele foi bem construído
será que na verdade a gente não tem uma
falácia sabe aquele argumento que até
parece bom mas na verdade é uma furada
por exemplo essa tão comum hoje em dia
quando alguém ao invés de se concentrar
no conteúdo da placa pessoa
o argumento contra a pessoa
então quando você faz isso você deixa de
construir em cima daquilo que importa
que é o próprio conteúdo tão sabendo
dessas três dicas você pode se
transformar em um melhor pensador
crítico e assim transformar
positivamente o seu entorno
com isso eu quero que eu quero trazer
para vocês é exatamente essa partilha de
um sonho que é o meu grande sonho
eu sonho que conversas como essa que nós
estamos tendo agora e oficinas como a
que eu contei para vocês no começo que
elas possam ser replicadas multiplicados
espalhadas em são carlos fora de são
carlos pelo brasil inteiro eu tenho esse
grande sonho e eu sonho também porque a
partir disso a gente possa construir uma
cidadania com cidadãos mais críticos com
cidadãos mais responsáveis e concidadãos
mais ativos
vocês me ajudam a construir esse sonho
vamos construir juntos esse sonho
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]